ellen pompeo posted this beautiful
tribute to you
your character on social media has over
2 million likes
what has her friendship meant to you
over the years
after this much time on a show i can
understand how
it would be difficult for someone to
sort of come in every day with the same
amount of
care and gusto and energy after all
those years and she does she cares so
much about the show
she fights for all the great choices
she's taught me a lot about the industry
and how it works and to me has been an
invaluable
friend and resource and mentor over the
years
no matter what happens i want you to
know that never felt seen the way you
saw me
i never felt inspired the way you
inspired me you made me want to be not
just
my best self but better it's been
amazing these past couple weeks to just
you know feel the outpouring of love
from all the fans
i didn't have time to respond to every
single person so if you're listening i
read them and i saw them and thank you
so much it means the world to know that
you were impacted by deluca and giacomo
is back
directing tonight's brand new episode of
grey's anatomy
honestly i was so happy when i got it
because it was just so
true to heart a grey's anatomy episode
you know what else she said that except
for her no one would miss me if i died
she thinks i'm a loner and no one cares
about me a lot of people panic on their
wedding day i know i did
dr hunt knows that
does this hurt ow so we got our medical
scenes we got
you know love and romance between our
main characters
and drama between our main characters a
healthy balance of inside the hospital
outside the hospital
and all the feels got some great
surgeries so um
no it's a really really great episode
and i'm really proud of it